like its namesake Kiwi shoe polish is a
bit of an odd bird with ingredients
common to products as diverse as chewing
gum and paint thinner first up is mag
gross a solvent that dyes animal skin
cells of the sort found in say fine
Italian leather thereby making them
stand out more distinctly diet pill
amino as a benzene and neither die it's
produced from the explosive extremely
unstable compound diazonium salt but
don't worry it won't blow up your
wingtips instead a nitrogen double bond
in the molecules of the dye absorbs and
reflects specific wavelengths of light
to make black brown or ox blood shoes
look even blacker browner or ox bloodier
though what makes them really shine is a
slick coating of carnauba wax used from
the leaves of Brazilian tree cop Anisha
printer Farah that same wax is also used
to provide the slick coating on floss
and the chewy texture of gum
finally there's heavy naphtha and
Stoddard solvent to petroleum
distillates which dissolve in spread wax
into a thin layer then evaporate meaning
you no longer have to set fire to your
shoe polish to use it like they do in
old movies so don't say we didn't warn
you
and remember no Kiwis were harmed in the
making of this video
feeling wired yet subscribe